[Music]
it's safe to say that if you're a fan of
counter-strike
esports or well the score esports
you've probably savored the smell of
gunfire and freedom
like a billion times cloud9 answering
back
twice as hard taking downhill
automatic with the kill and just like
that
clown nine in a one versus four
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
is 16 rounds
and cloud9 are in the grand finals of a
major tournament
from the reverse sweep in groups to
stewie's
famous behold you know the story of how
cloud9 took a bunch of scrappy pug stars
and did the impossible clawing their way
to north america's first
and only major championship in the
history of cs go
guardian waits patiently as cloud9 sets
the push up
oh oh this happens they made
it work cloud nine are your
league major champions now what you may
not know
is that it wasn't just rush taric tim
scadatti and the smoke criminal who took
home that title
it was also their coach soham
valens chaudhry the secret ingredient
and unsung hero behind cloud9's historic
success you see unlike a lot of coaches
valens isn't just a former competitor
who hashed up masterful machinations and
motivational speeches
no he's actually a stanford educated
tech obsessed genius who left behind
roles at some of the world's
most prestigious companies to not only
compete in and
coach professional counter-strike but
make it a little more
calculated and of course to help nacs
become
a little bit less of a meme and more of
a science
what's interesting is like this meme of
nacs whatever right i feel like we do a
lot of stuff that's
unique and we make it work and
eventually that becomes kind of like
a meta for that map but we're doing
things that are like
could be super stupid so what inspired
valence to give up his life as a
world-class coder for a shot in cs go
in what sense did his numbers-driven
approach help his region win their only
major
and how is he hoping to disseminate it
throughout not only counter-strike
but esports at large last time you came
and talked to us we won the mate
[Music]
okay so before we molly car and full
send it up banana be sure to
like the video subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications
that way you'll know straight away as
soon as we put out another video
that includes bardolph screaming look at
the time cause
i mean we will it never gets old all
right so in order to understand how
valen
started going all moneyball and cs go we
first need to understand his origins
outside of gaming when i say that valens
was a big-brained brov
i don't mean it by esports's colloquial
basement dwelling standards i mean it by
silicon valley standards valens
studied at stanford and as he talked
about on the ddk show
shortly after finishing his masters in
electrical engineering
took a job at what was then a promising
and extremely prestigious
little startup you may have even heard
of it it's called
tesla when you were there it it felt
very kind of just like everyone has like
a
single vision i saw elon musk walking
around every single day
it kind of was humbling as well that
these guys were willing to get their
hands dirty
and just kind of mingle with everyone
else because they just wanted to see
their company succeed as well
and as he went on to tell ddk it was at
tesla
that valenz's fiery passion for
analytics and data-driven
problem-solving was first ignited
it was there he realized that underneath
every human activity whether to do with
cars or
counter-strike there are numbers that
tell a story
kind of my job there was to proactively
using the data that was coming in from
the cars
that were being driven all over the road
using that data to proactively figure
out
if there was something wrong with the
car before the user and the driver
actually experienced it no one had ever
tried that before in the automobile
industry i think that's kind of where
my first taste of like oh like there's a
bunch of data here that no one has seen
before what cool things can you do with
it start getting that treatment of
thought running
is kind of where the data science aspect
of my career kind of came from the thing
is
devoted as he was to his job valens
wanted to build something for himself
it just so happened that right as he was
switching to freelance
cs go started getting big having put his
love for esports on the back burner
whilst in college
valence took the opportunity in 2014 to
go
whole hog into global offensive as a
competitor
bolton m4
looks like lauren going to take down
skadoodles the opera has been dealt with
and a great little catch on today's
you know i wasn't known as the most
mechanically gifted player
and part of the reason is i actually
really just like
watching the game and strategizing way
more than actually
you know getting in the dm and like a
mapping and like working on my aim
in the first place unfortunately velen's
playing career didn't end up being as
illustrious as he'd hoped
after spending about a year and a half
hopping across such rosters as
savage denial nihilum and even
complexity
valens found himself being released from
coal at the tail end of 2015.
it was then that valens had a choice to
make continue on in esports and
hopefully find a way to put his
revolutionary numbers driven ideas to
use or accept a full-time position at
another
well-reputed tech company known as
google
guess which one he chose the initial
reason that i wanted to join
google full-time i would say towards the
end of complexity i kind of realized
that there was probably like a year or
two years between
that ending and esports really taking
off where
data science and analytics would
actually make a difference
uh from the org perspective in esports
so i said okay i'm gonna put
my playing career on pause and let me
explore this google opportunity
and make sure my data science skill sets
kind of stayed
up to stuff but as fate would have it
esports wasn't finished with valence
the thing is it latched back onto him
not for his moves on the server
but his mind and tim's automatic i think
is
is a huge influence in my decision
making and he was like
hey we're thinking of making this team
on tsm they're going away from their
danish team
at the time they wanted to build an n a
you know roster
he actually asked me i remember
initially you still want to play
and i said i don't think so i think i
want to move more
to the coaching side and remember back
then coaching had a lot of
influence even in the game like live in
the game server it really was like
moving a bunch upon
pawn and chess pieces like and that
definitely influenced my decision to
kind of come try it out part time
the question of course was whether he'd
be any good
all the teams that valence has led
strategically and valence will be the
the in-game leader
from the coaching position uh denial
nilem cole they were never
known for strong and effective tactics i
mean they weren't known as these
tactical teams baylen's gonna be leading
full-time from the coaching position and
i can't see how
fns and cephas are really going to help
him out strategically and tactically
to to make that kind any kind of game
plan or any kind of system that is going
to find this team's success
for one whole year valen's helped
spearhead tsm's
shiny new north american counter-strike
roster
to well varying forms of success you see
valence wasn't known for being a rigid
shot-caller he was a researcher and for
a roster
as young and inexperienced as tsm
that wasn't enough still valence had
learned so much
juggling his time between tsm and google
and was so convinced that his analytics
could yield stellar results
that he committed to going into esports
full-time
a lot of discussions happen between
myself and jack the ceo of
cloud9 to see look you know this is how
i envision counter-striking esports
could be played using some more advanced
statistics
let me show you jack he just saw a lot
of value in actually
bringing someone full-time on board that
is doing
not just the coaching but also the
strategizing and analytics
for esports at cloud9 in general what
valens needed was a roster that was both
confident and self-sufficient enough
that they could benefit from his
coaching without having to rely on it
as he saw it his strength lay in
enabling players
not instructing them he didn't need
soldiers he needed [ __ ] disturbers
and thankfully north america had
a few of those molly what's coming laura
i
think
not on it
[Laughter]
in february of 2017 valence followed his
boy automatic
to cloud9 the organization that north
america's rowdiest
most ragtag mixture of bunnyhopping
smoke-pushing rank s pug stars
would eventually call home but valens
didn't just see it as an opportunity to
prove himself he saw it as a chance to
innovate
the question again was how well what
separated
this iteration of cloud9 from its shroud
and nothing predecessor
wasn't just their youth it was the way
they lived and died by this sort of
puggy precocious new school style of
counter-strike
nacs i think at least for me it means
kind of just like when
when like [ __ ] is going down but you
don't know why
and like you know because of that you're
you're like your teammate
gets killed or like you know things that
you don't intend to happen are happening
and you don't know like why
i think that's like the epitome of like
when people are saying nacs the thing is
whereas others saw a bunch of me me
misfits
valens saw a sea of untapped potential
here you had five undeniably gifted
gunners
so instead of trying to stifle train or
tame them valens figured why not
give them a structure within which they
could do their thing
and eventually become the deadliest
[ __ ] clowns counter-strike had
ever seen nothing left to achieve stewie
trying to hunt him down
picks it up with a jump flashes us in
knife is sounding he's gonna get stabbed
crystal
oh my god what a brutal round by the end
of the year
ska stu tim tarik and rush had cemented
themselves as not only their region's
biggest sweethearts but question marks
going into the e-league boston major at
the start of 2018
no one expected cloud9 to go the
distance and
in a sense that's exactly why they did
stewie he hears it apex stepping a
little bit too soon
now body in so much trouble but kenny's
gonna be on the high ground getting the
kill
he almost went down himself there's body
picking it up and now it's a one versus
one
stewie versus kenny the smell of gunfire
and freedom in the air and stewie
picking up that kill
and cloud9 are in the semi finals stewie
is still here
there's still a chance fur is going to
walk right into it the timing's a double
he's done it still he's created a chance
absolutely unbelievable terry coming
through and he's going to get the kill
on fire now
foreign they're rushing in one at a time
there's no coordination
phelps just trying to be the hero
skadoodle will drop him in now
what can fur possibly do he needed
somebody else to stay alive and that
just hasn't happened
the molotov he's gonna challenge him the
hero
daddy's here for the triple and 50
rounds now for cloud9
it quickly became apparent that c9 were
somehow developing
this crisp yet chaotic cohesion
it felt as if they were pugging their
way to a major title and
valens was simply steering them in the
right direction what i would do is
really just think about okay what has
worked for us in practice that's
repeatable
and against other teams and then reign
it in to make sure we come up with a
game plan that fits
something that all five players are
comfortable with because we have reps on
it in practice
and let their innate ability of being
able to play out mid-round
in the chaos that'll be there you know
that will be there i don't have to teach
them that but make sure we're
in our game plan focusing on the stuff
that we know how to do extremely well
it's a 5v4
for cloud9 with 40 seconds to go and
kerrigan he can't reposition
he has the frag he has to frag and he
gets only one
and now that's cloud moving quickly
towards b they have the utility
but olive meister on the flank can he
catch brush it rush pops up
and rush is knocked down whack-a-mole
there for olive meister the guardian
still in position
they managed to get there fast enough
the bomb has to be planted and
cloud9 had a disadvantage tarik brave
enough to just
hold the bomb plant he knows guardians
in construction trying to back off
trying to reposition
sees him tags him but doesn't frag him
that around defined
i think our perseverance in in the
context of like
look there's a bunch of chaotic [ __ ]
happening faze is actually
trying to close out around and they're
not expecting us to peek
so let's just speak they're spamming the
grenades they're touching the bottom
and now goes brain another bomb that is
trying to defuse it again but no
guardian gets taken down absolutely
unreal ran from cloud9
and the score is tight the fact that
data can be
used to help teams improve and scout
other teams is
really icing on the cake ultimately when
you're playing the game you're in the
match
and you know the reg you know whatever
30 rounds are happening you need to
adapt to what's happening in front of
you and
at all times the coach should be the
person that knows the most of what are
possibles what is potentially likely to
happen but the player should just be
focusing on the game
when all was said and done valenz's job
wasn't so much to tell
c9 what to do it was to tell them what
their opponents were going to do
and then let them adjust accordingly one
thing that was super clear to us
during the game itself was that kerrigan
was calling in a way to get kills
early on his t side for map control and
if he didn't get them
he did not have a refined way to finish
the round
the rotation's being pulled
automatically coming off his position
the smoke the flashes
automatic slides could do he needs to
land some shots any years two kills for
him
don't take out your teammate he's gonna
stay alive now ten seconds for this bomb
to go down he must stay alive stewie
is going absolutely crazy on the b bomb
side there's no time to play the bomb
it's too late the money's not there one
more round
he's got to go back stewie's on his own
but look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
of blood they're trying to build
pyramids but it's no more crying
stewie's walking around we're going to
overtime
dogs how old they've done that
they came back all the way
needless to say cloud9's major run was
historic
for a variety of reasons but the one
aspect of it that might just be the most
overlooked is the cutting cutting-edge
nature of valenz's coaching
of course it wasn't long after achieving
eternal glory
the cloud9 cs go roster well imploded
still valens had proven that he was the
real deal
and at the end of 2019 was given an
invaluable opportunity to take things to
the next level
as evil geniuses head of data science
valens has truly managed to unite his
affinity for esports
with his undying love of analytics
expanding his horizons to such titles as
league of legends
dota 2 and valorant nicole who is the
ceo of
eg she had the best vision
and the one that aligned closest to mine
for not just having a data team for
helping with our internal teams like cs
go league of legends dota 2 but
making this a multi-year initiative have
data
be the central part of not just their
esports team strategizing but also
how are players performing on a
day-to-day basis in and out of the
server
so it's like a whole you know
encompassed data
driven culture at eg that i really liked
slowly but surely this stanford
educated cs fiend has succeeded in
making esports at large
just a little more calculated even if
his journey to getting there
was both born and bred in
well chaos you know we did the thing we
won the major
we proved that we could do it as a team
and
using numbers as well you got to start
with the questions if you don't know
what questions are actually worth
answering
it doesn't matter that you have the data
because you'll realize
someone's going to ask a question it
might be you yourself
that suddenly you don't have a data
point answer now
so then you have to go back rebuild
figure out where you get that data
you're going to go back to that step
anyway so ask the questions first
and then collect the data accordingly
and that has helped
enormously both in business and esports
once a year i send an email to valve hey
guys
have you considered giving coaches an
in-game trophy for the major i think
it'd be really cool
and show that valve supports coaches in
counter-strike
best so hump i've sent that three years
in a row
valve said they're looking into it they
might consider it
but so far i haven't yet gotten that
trophy in game